[Music]
so I'm a foreigner and I got accepted to
this research paper that I've been
working on for years
and when I got accepted to that I was
really happy that's something that I was
really proud of I'm an athlete I'm a
swimmer so yes I've been to Olympic
Trials in my country
I'd say fixing my grandfather's truck
with them and having to be proud
definitely when I finally got into SDSU
I'm an Eagle Scout so actually getting
that achievement um when my brothers
were adopted being a good sister
graduating high school with a 4.0 I
would have to say when I taught my
little sister had a cow in Vietnamese
like it's not a big thing but like it
took like three hours but I taught her
to cut to ten I feel really proud of
that so cause she still remembers katsu
um probably when I moved out here to San
Diego and I did about eight years in the
United States Navy had a lot of things
to be proud of and a lot of people be
proud of so
I think I'm most proud of
that I am able to take care of my
grandparents my grandmother now probably
when I was tutoring this one girl and
brought her math grade up from a Deaton
a I say my proudest moment was getting
valedictorian back in high school it was
pretty great day for me I think when I
graduated and I told my dad I was
actually gonna pursue my kind of kalinda
nearing I think he was really proud of
me then um my proudest moments so far is
going to NC double-a last year in Oregon
for the
4x1 and an individual event because
sophomore year I went just for a relay
engineer I went as individual and relay
you know I do something senior you
putting together a Jewish organization
in high school like being a leader in it
called us why moving out it was
something that I was terrified about and
I kind of
grew the gut to do it and it's been my
most proud moment I've been able to
manage it's not been easy but it's been
fun one time I like hit home run during
a bike class game and I was really
important I think my proudest moment has
been being published in the magazine for
modeling I got into Delta's to comply
business fraternity so I'm pretty proud
of that getting accepted into
professional ballet school that I really
wanted to go to and I was like 15
probably becoming a coach for my cabana
class of team that I've been a part of
since I was like five so yeah when I
wrote an article
about hunger strike in California
prisons and 3,000 people read it one day
my proudest moment is being the oldest
grandchild and being the first one that
went to college not only did I get my
bachelor's degree got my master's degree
and my doctoral degree going to the gym
like every day for the past two months
when my dad got one of my drawings
tattooed on him I started my own company
as a personal trainer there and that
just went very well from the beginning
and I had a lot of clients so I still
have that I'm very proud of them
probably work on my motorcycle yeah when
my dad rescued a man from a burning car
over summer for a week I had the highest
score in America and subway surfers it's
like a game on your phone it's like this
dude is like just running on top of like
subway trains so yeah I had the highest
score in America for a week and I had
the highest score for my facebook friend
itself
[Music]